I want to talk about this next story but
I want to issue a sort of disclaimer
first this is one of those stories that
is an important story but we need to
remember that it also could be an
attempt to distract from the closing
noose of criminality around Donald
Trump's neck like with ending birthright
citizenship which since Trump mentioned
it we've basically heard not a word
about it at all
sometimes Trump says crazy things to
distract from more pressing problems
that he's facing right in the moment and
in the moment right now he is facing a
lot of problems triggered beta male big
baby
petulant child Donald Trump is so upset
about Saturday Night Live making fun of
him that he's now ignoring free speech
ignoring media freedom and he wants
Saturday Night Live's comedy tested in
courts what on earth could he be talking
about well Trump is questioning the
legality of Saturday Night Live and
questioning the legality of media
coverage in general that is critical of
him Donald Trump tweeted over the
weekend bizarrely quote a real scandal
is the one sided coverage hour by hour
of networks like NBC and Democrats spin
machines like Saturday Night Live it is
all nothing less than unfair news
coverage and Democratic commercials
should be tested in courts can't be
legal only defame and belittle collusion
aside from being sort of a very strange
dr. Seuss like tweet in it's sort of
cadence this is a very strange contrast
because on the one hand you have Donald
Trump calling actual news fake news but
then he wants satirical news like
Saturday Night Live tested in court what
would you even test it for right I mean
it's a comedy show maybe Donald Trump
doesn't understand that is it is it
possible that Donald Trump sees that
Weekend Update segment that looks like a
newscast in SNL and thinks that that's
real news in some way and thinks that
that should be tested and in some I mean
I don't even know the other tragedy is
that Trump cares more about being
made fun of by a few comedians on
Saturday Night Live then he seemed to
care when the entire United Nations
General Assembly was laughing at him
right in his face he's more concerned
with satirical news sketches on Saturday
Night Live than he was when the world
leaders laughed at him and the obvious
question for the White House after this
bizarre tweet was what did Donald Trump
mean when he said he wanted Saturday
Night Live tested in court what what
exactly is the legal plan for that and
not surprisingly no comment coming from
the White House this is part of a
concerted attack on media it started
with fake news as a sort of catch-all ad
hominem for news that Trump doesn't like
it then primed people to disbelieve any
news that was critical of Trump of
Trump's actions as president and it
actually sort of successfully greased
Trump up with a proverbial petroleum
jelly where any critical news or
reporting about him just slid right off
if you imagine that visual imagery
because his supporters were primed to
disbelieve it because of the fake news
meme then he suggested opening up libel
laws to make it easier to sue media
outlets unnecessary I mean we already
have laws that allow media outlets to be
sued for actual wrongdoing rather than
just because you want to suppress their
speech then Trump floated the idea of
journalism licenses and maybe of taking
away such licenses which don't really
exist other than the fact that broadcast
facilities have licenses to broadcast
then there was the idea of banning
people from press briefings that he
didn't like like Jim Acosta so to sum up
Pat I would encourage him try to take
SNL to court that would be the epitome
of the triggered petrol and child that
he is but secondly it's important that
we keep an eye on this Pat because it's
this continued barrage of attacks on
media but not allow ourselves to be
distracted from the serious criminality
by Trump and family and associates which
is being exposed weekly because it's
much more favorable to Trump for us to
be talking about oh he wants to sue SNL
than the fact that he directed Michael
Cohen to commit fell
and the right-wingers who are so
passionate about the Constitution and
when it comes to guns in the Second
Amendment they should really take a look
at this because it sounds to me like an
attack on the First Amendment and what
it also boils down to is the fact that
Trump just can't take a joke he's way
too thin-skinned he can't poke fun at
himself
SNL makes fun of everyone they make fun
of every president and Trump does give
them a lot of material but at the end of
the day he just he just can't take it he
can't take it he's never been able to
take it and he wants to dish it out and
not have to take it because he is the
sort of extreme epitome of a triggered
snowflake I don't like to adopt their
language when it's offensive but this is
sort of what they are trying to describe
by saying someone is a triggered
snowflake it describes Trump more than
anyone else I've ever seen send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
one of today's sponsors is Skillshare
which is an amazing online learning
community that offers thousands of
high-quality classes on almost any topic
first 500 people who click the link
under this video will get two entire
months of totally free access to every
single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything from
design video editing photography
business technology cooking meditation
even classes on personal productivity I
know you'll be able to find something on
Skillshare that fascinates you or even
something that will help you in your
everyday life classes are taught by real
people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the david pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of Skillshare but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up